hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast Anna just checking in on you
just checking in on you I'm actually
recording this ones day before the game
seven just [ __ ] with you
it's Thursday I watched the game I know
what happened all right I got to say
congratulations to the st. Louis Blues
on your first Stanley Cup championship
ever avenging your mother's day's loss
was it May 13th 1970 something like that
40 [ __ ] nine years later I'm not
gonna lie to you I had a smile on my
face when I was watching all those st.
Louis Blues fans going crazy and one of
my favorite things in the world is
watching a franchise that hasn't won in
forever win it but I feel like I got
[ __ ] over because they beat my team so
I couldn't fully enjoy it the same way
like I you know I was rooting for the
Eagles you know to win a Super Bowl I
just didn't want him to beat the
Patriots so both of those you know I
felt like I would have enjoyed way more
obviously if they weren't beating my
team but like Jesus Christ hats off to
the st. Louis Blues organization they
played a [ __ ] masterful game seven it
was such a great series where it was
really just the speed of the Bruins
versus this physical will of the Blues
what was going to win and I got to say
old freckles kind of called it did he
not did he not I said the way to beat
the Blues is you got to score first and
pull him out of that [ __ ] trap
defense that they were playing which
would open up the ice for our speed and
that's what happened in game like Game
three and Game six and when they went up
one enough and I was like [ __ ] we need
we need to get this next goal we need to
get this next goal we can't have them we
can't have them up - oh I mean I haven't
seen the trap defense played that well
since the boring-ass New Jersey Devils
won three cups some of the worst
I've ever seen in my life as far as
excitement went but what I loved about
the way the Blues played it was as much
as I was kind of being a [ __ ] [ __ ]
about it I actually in the end really
enjoyed the way they played playing
outside the lines a little bit but that
is playoff hockey and you know I was
looking up some hockey stats before Game
seven
the Bruins back in the day when the
Canadians would always beat us you know
Don Cherry was our coach and that
something I read was just he told him to
have their sticks up high around guila
floor and we still didn't beat him
bookie Lafleur's whole [ __ ] head was
swollen and cut up by the end of this
series so we've done [ __ ] like that so I
would be a real [ __ ] pansy here if I
was to complain about some of the
rougher stuff and just the bottom line
was we I said it dude I said it said you
don't want to go seven games with this
team because you're gonna be too beat up
by the end you know if you're the
finesse team you gotta win you gotta win
it in five or six or they're just gonna
weigh you down the way I saw him wear
down San Jose which is exactly what they
did and I was too hard on Billington I
said he was astoundingly mediocre I was
as hard on him as they have been overly
complimenting him alright first rookie
goaltender ever won 16 games it's like
Patrick Wall only 115 in 1986 because
you could only win 15 alright the first
round was best three out of five
so it's not his fault that he couldn't
have beat their ass another [ __ ] game
not to mention he won the Conn Smythe
and he had a one point nine two goals
against average that my thing about
Billington was this and he had four
[ __ ] stand on your head
saves in a game seven so you can never
take that away from that guy but that
guy was definitely a different
goaltender when he was down okay when we
went in Game six when we actually
[ __ ] got a little physical and we
went up you know look at we we we went
up a goal you know the same thing we did
in Game three all of a sudden the guys
giving up five goals a game and getting
pulled out of one game so last night
what I was watching the problem that we
were having and I've never seen a team
four check as well as
in recent memory the st. Louis Blues
what they kept talking about their
goaltender it I don't know what the
[ __ ] game they were watching what the
game was between the goaltender's and
like have you ever seen a [ __ ] team
like they stopped like every [ __ ]
past we made there was like every time a
Bruin had a puck that was like there was
like a clock thousand one thousand two
get rid of it get rid of it or they
would they were just gonna come up and
just physically take it away from you
we had the amount of passes that we
would like through the air like saucer
pass trying to do it and they would just
bat it down out of the air like they had
a like a [ __ ] I don't know like they
had a goaltender stick it was
unbelievable how [ __ ] amazing they
were at that I'm not good with the names
cuz I got a kid now and I gotta watch
the game with the [ __ ] sound down but
that number nine on the blues I can't
remember to your first to second goal
would we I think crazy somebody had the
puck and he just knocked him down kept
it in our zone and I was like and then
you know they're passing it they're
passing they're keeping it in the zone
the whole time ago if they score here
then that number nine should get a
[ __ ] assistant sure enough they ended
up scoring I think on the tip shot or I
can't remember it was sort of the
partial breakaway backhand or that guy
got by Tuukka but the big thing was to
beat them you had to go up because when
you went up then Billington came back
down to earth and the problem last night
as we got down and we got down early and
then he got to stay behind the cushy
confines of the way they were playing
that [ __ ] trap defense and we did not
have a power forward was what was
lacking on our team we needed a guy in
the slot taken the punishment and we
were too beat up and just didn't have
that [ __ ] guy so what was happening
is when we got into their offensive zone
if he won't we watch the game the amount
of times we had the puck in a good
position and we would pass all the way
to the other side of the ice go wing to
wing and an NHL goaltender that's all
day to go from post to post and we just
didn't get any traffic in front and too
many of our shots from were from out
near the blue line where he had a wide
open look I mean by the time we finally
got traffic out in front and scored on
him it took us six on five we had to
have an extra guy so somebody could
stand out in front
and I don't know I love the blues
aggressive style the way that they
played and and they knocked us on our
ass and we have to get bigger and
stronger congratulations the Bruins they
went way further this year than I
thought they were going to you know we
definitely got it you know we got rid of
too many like Shaun Thornton's and Lou
cheech's and Adam McQuaid's where we
couldn't hit him back and that was
really really hard to watch as a Bruins
fan because I've never seen us get
physically dominated like that but I
don't know I don't know I don't know it
kind of ended up going the way I thought
I was gonna go and I was honest the
other day when I said I had absolutely
no feeling on which way it was gonna go
in Game seven which I don't know how you
could because if you watched the Bruins
in game 1 game 3 and game 6 you would
think that the Blues couldn't play with
us and then if you watch the Bruins in
game [ __ ] two four five and seven you
would have thought we would have got
swept it was such a [ __ ] weird series
where it was it was almost like just
whoever got out front first like that
was it and the game was going to be
played the way they played it you know
if the Bruins got out front it was going
to be a speed game and we were gonna win
and Billington was gonna let up four or
five [ __ ] goals or they got out front
and and [ __ ] it was just gonna be
this physical game and we were we were
going to play eighty percent of the game
in our in our own [ __ ] end but I
don't know I can tell you this though
that's going to be a hell of a party on
and on Saturday down there in st. Louis
you guys totally deserve it
we're really at the end of the day we're
the better team I'm being a little kunti
with your goaltender and it has nothing
that this isn't a personal attack on the
guy I'm just so [ __ ] sick of like
sports casters in sports networks the
way they spew out stats with no sort of
historical perspective is the same way a
politician you know will fudge numbers
and [ __ ] to me this guy doesn't like
babies you know he voted no on this
[ __ ] thing and they don't look at
what's attached to the [ __ ] bill as
to why this person voted no like this
[ __ ] horse [ __ ] where it's just like
this guy just had more wins and Kent
Dryden it's like when Ken Dryden played
I think he needed he needed eight
there's only two rounds of the playoffs
or you'd be watching like major league
baseball and be like I'll here's a stat
that just came in so and so just past
Babe Ruth the salt and the SWAT for most
postseason playoffs it's like there was
the back and Babe Ruth played it was
like whoever had the most wins in the
American League that was winning the
pennant there was no playoff you just
immediately went to the World Series so
the best you could do is play seven
games in a year so now you could play
what is it the first rounds the best of
five
you could play five and another four you
played 19 [ __ ] games in one year now
so obviously you're gonna start patting
these guys sit down I mean who's gay
though I'm a brother there's a reason
why we're all sitting here at ok this
kid right now he's got a bet he's
pinching himself seeing his name up and
against a [ __ ] guard attack attack
it's just I don't understand that it's
just like well obviously if somebody's
gonna play three times as many games
potentially every [ __ ] year of their
career they're gonna start passing some
[ __ ] amazing people you know like
Martin Brodeur my main memory of this
Hall of Fame great goaltender was him
stopping dump and chase passes behind
his [ __ ] neck you know the best I saw
was Patrick wah that's the best I ever
[ __ ] soft so that's why being a bit
of a [ __ ] being a bit of a [ __ ] it
definitely [ __ ] you know was [ __ ]
hilarious as I watched the game in a
cigar bar I was so [ __ ] sad when I
left I forgot my credit card I gotta go
back and get that today but I I was in
there I'm in New York nobody gave a [ __ ]
about the [ __ ] game I had to tell him
to turn the game on and when the Blues
scored the first time
on the deflection the insult to injury
was I was sitting there and somebody
just goes oh did they just score and
then he's watched the replayed he goes
oh a wrecker Shay it's just like oh my
god
Oh rekha Shay okay anyways but uh
and then once New York fans realized
that I was rooting for Boston they
started giving me [ __ ] and I [ __ ]
destroyed them and then they all had to
shut the [ __ ] up because they got
nothing they got nothing they got [ __ ]
97 [ __ ] - what anybody gonna chant at
me huh what 2008 with the [ __ ] Boston
Celtics the [ __ ] out of here
so anyway and then I ended up [ __ ]
leaving it Nate a slice of pizza like
did you see I loved what's-his-face l
president barroso he took him just
eating all kinds of bad food that's what
I did I went I got to so I was watching
the game with Bobby Kelly and then I
went he dropped me off when I'm staying
here in New York and I went over I just
got a slice of pizza from the better
famous raised in the area and just sat
there by myself like that weird [ __ ]
feeling you know when you're that close
and you [ __ ] lose and then it's the
double whammy of not only did you lose
but that's the end of hockey for the
year which by the way Thank You Canada
for hockey Jesus Christ I still maintain
it's the [ __ ] it's the best of the
four sports it's just sitting there
eating that [ __ ] thing by myself
going a [ __ ] and now I get into the
podcast and I got to eat crow the next
[ __ ] day what was [ __ ] me but I'm
over it and all right so now that I've
been a bit of a [ __ ] to your goaltender
which he really doesn't deserve so 1967
I'm going off the top of my head cuz one
of these mall where [ __ ] we know
things took over my computer I have a
brand new laptop and it already watch
out when they say you need the new flash
whatever your Flash Player needs to be
updated I clicked on that so now
I have to spend a [ __ ] day this week
at the [ __ ] Apple store figuring out
how to get rid of this [ __ ] thing may
all you [ __ ] hackers out there burn
in hell all you [ __ ] out the [ __ ]
[ __ ] who did this it's like you
can't go after bankers you can't go
after [ __ ] real prey you got to
[ __ ] get some dumb bald [ __ ]
redheaded [ __ ] whose team just lost a
Stanley Cup final you got to [ __ ]
take over my computer so you can make
more money off at JC Penney you [ __ ]
[ __ ] so anyways sad sack fans so
this morning I got to go downstairs into
the laundry room of where I'm staying
here and to do my laundry here right so
I go downstairs to go do it
you figure Thursday morning there's not
going to be anybody here but actually
most of machines were taken up and
fortunately I got one and so I ended up
going downstairs you know after the
washing thing was done and this guy
sitting there when these [ __ ]
[ __ ] it does his laundry like once a
leap year he's got all these bags of
[ __ ] and he's like taking up all the
machines and he starts going like yeah
I'm just still waiting for one more like
worried like I'm gonna take one I go oh
that one's mine it's almost done he's
like alright and why he's mine son he's
like you want this you want this like
trying to get me to take the basket you
know over and it's just like buddy relax
right so I take my [ __ ] out and you know
the stuff I'm gonna just let dry him the
apartment I fold that and then I put my
socks and underwear is into the dryer
and then all of a sudden he comes around
the corner with this load of wet laundry
and goes I'm just gonna leave this here
right I'm like what he goes I'm just
gonna leave this here I'm like what the
[ __ ] is he talking about
then I realized that was somebody else's
laundry I'm like is that somebody else's
laundry he's like yeah I go dude don't
drag me into this he goes what I go
don't drag me into this that's not my
laundry don't ask for my okay like I'm
the sultan of the [ __ ] laundry room
he's a good you doesn't say anything
likes guys a [ __ ] selfish [ __ ] right
so I walk out just one of those people
you just want to get away from so I go
out and I push the button and I'm
waiting for the [ __ ] elevator right
and I looked up I realized I didn't push
the button cuz I'm so still thinking
about the [ __ ] game and what we could
have done which is all futile at this
point
and I hit the UP button and all of a
sudden he comes walking out so now it's
like I got a [ __ ] I got a right up
with this [ __ ] so I'm like well you
know what I'm the first floor of
apartments so worst case scenario he
gets off on my floor you know you know
what this [ __ ] [ __ ] does you know
what he does you know what he does he
gets in the elevator and he pushes Lobby
you [ __ ] bleep he got on my elevator
okay which is a thing my elevator is a
thing if you get on it first it's your
[ __ ] elevator if somebody gets on
after you and then [ __ ] hits the
floor before you're getting off they
interrupted your life twice and they
should apologize when they get off I do
it that's my that's my elevator
etiquette there's anything worse when
you're in a tall [ __ ] building you're
coming down in some [ __ ] [ __ ] on
18 hits it and he gets on and then
[ __ ] hit 17 it's like he couldn't
take the stairs you know you wear your
wingtips we're gonna get scuffed up
would you turn the corner bill what are
you really mad at Oh my team lost
goddamnit oh it's gonna say this is off
the top of my head the expansion six if
I remember correctly was the
Philadelphia Flyers Pittsburgh Penguins
the Minnesota North Stars the st. Louis
Blues the LA Kings
in the California golden seals so the
California golden seals then I think
became the Oakland seals and somehow
they ended up in Cleveland and became
the Cleveland Barons and then they
folded or maybe a few of them sort of
combined with Minnesota North Stars I
can't quite remember what happened to
them so they never won one let's see if
I can do is top of my head all right the
Flyers won at first 74 and 75 then the
next ones to win it were let's see here
would it be the Dallas stop Minnesota
then be the Dallas Stars in 1999
now the Pittsburgh Penguins they want it
Flyers the Penguins the Dallas Stars in
99 then the LA Kings and then the
[ __ ] st. Louis Blues won it last
night so it took 52 years 53 seasons for
the expansion six all of those great
[ __ ] teams that added so much to
hockey doubled the league to finally
have the last one win the Stanley Cup
here's the way thing about hockey right
let's say you had a 16 League and you
were adding another six team so we're
obviously going to be weak right because
they're new teams
okay how would you divide those up if
you're gonna make two conferences
wouldn't you take three of the original
in won three of the new and three of the
original six and the other and three
hockey didn't do that they kept all the
original six in one division and put all
the expansion six in another definition
so the first round of the playoffs was
basically the Stanley Cup final between
the two [ __ ] original six teams and
that's why I believe we swept the Blues
in 1970 last time you played they were
like a [ __ ] brand new franchise so
anyway was there anything else that I
wanted to talk about as far as hockey I
can't live I literally cannot even go on
my computer any what's funny is I tried
refreshing and clearing all my web
browser history and I lost all my
passwords I can't even get into my
[ __ ] email it's a [ __ ] nightmare
so now I'm gonna go over and you know
talk to one of the geniuses at the Apple
Store to see if they can funk and figure
out one of the evil geniuses who came up
with this malware horseshit I've now
realized I'm not clicking on anything
anymore okay I'm done with this shitty
I'm gonna get a rotary phone if you want
to get in contact with me just [ __ ]
call me maybe I'll be home maybe I won't
be I'm just gonna go back to old school
[ __ ] because you know I was telling you
when you know I have these acting gigs
when I go down
the the the set there you know in
between setups I don't bring my phone or
anything because I just feel he just
takes me out of what little game I have
as an actor I was actually down there
there was a book on a coffee table and I
actually started reading it I was like
this is what I should be doing between
[ __ ] you know when there was when
there's a long turnaround like it's
gonna be like a [ __ ] half-hour you
don't to keep doing the lines in your
head because then you're gonna be like a
robot when you go out there at least
that's how I'm wired but actually
reading a book an old man old lady thing
to do it's [ __ ] it's a [ __ ] I could
believe how enjoyable it was it was
actually it turned out through who's
Pete Holmes his book comedy God which I
immediately thought was funny I'm like
are is he just doing this thing where
he's like overly bragging doing like a
run burgundy thing and it was actually a
lot of look for I was skimming reading
was a lot of it was about like him being
brought up in religious and religion
overly religious and getting into
stand-up and I read a couple of chapters
of his book and I was trying to find to
see if he had mentioned the first time I
ever worked with him just to see what
his take was on that weekend the first
time I ever worked with Pete Holmes I
worked in at this comedy club I don't
even still out there was called
Brewster's in Peoria Illinois hometown
of the great late great Richard Pryor
greatest comedian of all time and we did
this gig out there I just remembered it
was like mostly a bar and on stage it
was sort of done up like this Old West
kind of thing with like these big
whiskey barrels and looking like
provisions and [ __ ] were like we were
gonna go on the [ __ ] Oregon Trail or
something we're up on the up on stage I
believe a long time ago he actually
posted a video of him bombing during
that weekend we both went out and
watched the ring in an empty movie
theater was the two of us and both got
scared shitless watching that thing and
had a great [ __ ] weekend working with
him so I was trying to get to that part
where he first moved to New York but I
actually read the part where his
marriage first marriage fell apart man
that [ __ ] guy's a great writer so
check out that book if you get a chance
there's also another book
that just came out on greg Giraldo which
i didn't even know was coming out so I
don't even know who wrote the thing I
just saw Bobby Kelly promoted it on his
Instagram so I'm definitely going to get
that book you know I don't know I don't
know I'm too happy but I don't know what
I'm doing I'm [ __ ] devastated
I really am devastated my [ __ ]
beloved Bruins lost and I'm also oddly
really happy for st. Louis you know
long-suffering fans it's just a weirdest
[ __ ] feeling I was actually sitting
there with Bobby and we just gonna do
you believe this [ __ ] [ __ ] I was
just like they play with it but they're
the better team they're the better team
and when they raised the cup just you
know excited the guys actually had a
smile on his face and Bobby's okay I was
like dude I [ __ ] love this [ __ ] this
is the best [ __ ] trophy ever but I I
would be lying to you if I am NOT
[ __ ] if I didn't say I wasn't [ __ ]
devastated right now Jesus Christ and
then then that's it thank God for MotoGP
thank God I got into motorcycle racing
because to go from the end of the
[ __ ] NHL playoffs and just the level
of intensity you know trying to ease
your way you know into [ __ ] the dog
days of [ __ ] baseball you know I
always equate it must be like what Ric
Flair felt like after doing a road of
you know a run of wrestling and then cut
trying to come home to his family life
and trying to come down from [ __ ]
whoa style and profile analogy screamin
it's like the fan version of that so
thank God for [ __ ] MotoGP and I get
to watch those [ __ ] amazing lunatics
race those bikes around at 200 miles an
hour
and I'm not [ __ ] on baseball because
I do love baseball actually you know
I've been so into the NBA Finals and the
Stanley Cup final that you know the
other day when there was a there was a
day off I actually was like I have to
watch some sort of competition here and
I watched the Yankees Mets game and I
was able to get into it I prefer the
Yankee feet over the met feet
because I'm more familiar with that
Michael Kay and all of that and I also
love listening to Paul O'Neill and um
but I was just sitting there I don't
know I have to tell you this so let's
let's talk control in the end
congratulations to the st. Louis Blues
congratulations to Billington for
proving me wrong I mean he had just
forced stand on your head [ __ ] saves
in a game seven I mean you don't get
lucky like that I think the kid is the
[ __ ] real deal all right there I said
it
but I've gotten so into this NBA final
final Jesus Christ jumping back and
forth here I was initially for Toronto
and I still really kind of am because of
the Toronto fans but I have to tell you
at first I was making fun of Drake now I
love him because I find myself watching
him when the balls being brought to
court like he is so out of his [ __ ]
mind
he's he's literally spacing the
sidelines like he's coaching the team
like I was watching him when they were
bringing the ball up and he was just
manically making this spread like spread
the offense [ __ ] gesture and I'm
going like this guy has lost his [ __ ]
mind like he's doing [ __ ] that like I do
in my living room when I know nobody's
watching he's doing this on television
so part of me I don't want Toronto to
win because I want to see this again I
don't want to see satisfied Drake I want
to see longing for a championship Drake
and that last game watching the Warriors
show why they're [ __ ] champions you
know and I'm not you know I didn't get
upset with Toronto fans cheering when KD
went down that was that was fear more so
than disrespect that was just like oh
thank god this guy is out alright
although there was that one [ __ ]
in the front row you know who was
dressed sort of like you know he looked
like he listened to [ __ ] remember
those awful rap metal bands from the
early 2000s he looked like a fan of one
of those beds and he was like waving
bye-bye and it's just like yo who the
[ __ ] does that who does that right so
this is what I think happens in that
series
I think Golden State I don't but you got
Leonard Leonard it's just [ __ ] ice
water when you won't even give a fist
pound to one of your own [ __ ] players
that's when you know you're in this note
he's like the [ __ ] Marshawn Lynch
like his attitude where he doesn't give
a [ __ ] about anything except when he you
saw that quote when they split at home
and they were going out to Golden State
and the I'm I said the teacher the coach
was going you know we go out there we
did we get one we do all we gonna do is
win one game and he speaks up and said
[ __ ] that let's win two and then they
did he's like [ __ ] John Wayne in a
Western so I don't know I don't actually
I gotta be honest with you I will be
happy either way watching this series no
matter what happens I will you know in
the end I think I want to see Toronto
win a little more just cuz they haven't
won a championship and so long but like
the next championship I really wanted to
see Toronto when it was I wanted to see
them win a cup you know I will tell you
though anytime I see Toronto fans
gathering outside watching something on
a screen I get a negative feeling going
like oh how many times we've seen this
they gradually start peeling off it's
one of the saddest slowest departures of
a fanbase you're ever gonna [ __ ] see
but god bless them because they do show
up so I wanted to go seven games my gut
feeling is Golden State comes out in
wins Game six and then loses Game seven
in Toronto I just think Toronto might
wear him down by that point
Golden State is really banged up but I
will tell you what would be [ __ ] sick
as if Toronto goes into their building
and [ __ ] ends their dynasty in their
own building Oh
oh you know what that would take me back
to 1985 when Kareem hit that last
[ __ ] skyhook I never forget that and
he ran down the court and he [ __ ] me
he balled up both his fists like that's
it we got these [ __ ] and I was
just like they finally beat us in the
final finals all right and with that
let's let's read let's read a couple of
[ __ ] advertisements here for the
podcast all right we got butcher box
everybody uh do I love these guys
this much this month munch I'm already
think about eating this month butcher
box is offering free bacon for life sign
up now and you'll get one package of the
best-tasting bacon free and every box
for the life of your subscription
butcher box bacon is hole 30 approved
whatever that means uncured nitrate and
sugar free right now new members will
get a package of bacon for free in every
box for the life of your subscription
plus you'll get $20 off your first box
this is incredible quality of butcher
the incredible quality of butcher box
meats starts with the commitment to
humanely raised animals that are never
fed antibiotics are home or hormones
they're shown Disney movies before
they're slaughtered that we mentioned
it's delivered right to your door to
receive $20 off your first box and a
package of free bacon in every box for
the life of your subscription go to
butcher box.com slash burrow or enter
burn the check out at checkout go now
limited time offer you know just to let
you know my favorite is the Heritage
bread pork okay that is just the best
pork chop I have a [ __ ] head
everything's high-quality grass-fed
grass-finished free-range organic
chicken heritage breed pork is how
you're supposed to say it I'm telling
you it's the only the ad read I have on
my mouth waters as I'm reading it
thinking about that [ __ ] good food
all right dude do me on these B undies
singing the [ __ ] blues doo doo doo
doo
Meah nice we lost now what do you do
you leave your credit card and get us
slice the other team one and that's not
nice I'm gonna cry until October but
even Abba do boo-boo oh shout out to
James talent Harris one of the New York
Kings of Comedy one of the New York
kings of comedy acting like a sports
Queen no text message when we won the
World Series no text message when we won
the Superbowl we lose the Stanley Cup
final typical New York fan pops his
[ __ ] head up Jesus Christ surprised I
didn't hear from Rob Stapleton he's
another [ __ ] half-ass fan never around
during the losses and then like their
whack Amole fans then did then their
comedy Kings on stage when it comes to
[ __ ] sports fans they're [ __ ]
Queens all right sure I'll be hearing
from both of them now all right me
undies there are two types of dudes in
the world yeah Bobby Kelly Keith
those that go through the gate and those
that go over the fence well after all
these years of research and countless
experiments with seasoned underwear
scientists the undies now has options
for both with their new boxer briefs
with a fly it took a while but now men
from both sides of the aisle can enjoy
the world's softest undies the undies
uses the coveted micro motile modal
fabric which is a full three times
softer than cotton not only will you
feel like your loins are being hugged by
joy itself but me undies gives you
multiple style options for both men and
women men can try out the new
boxer-brief with a fly with a fly you're
gonna have metal that close to your dick
that's why I never understood people who
go [ __ ] Nature Boy you know what I
mean don't you wear your balls I'm gonna
get snagged in the zipper huh you never
so [ __ ] nuff mama said my cousin Mary
there's something about Mary men cannot
try the new boxer-brief with the fly
it's the same great cutters boxer-brief
just with a hole for number one me
undies for number one fellas do not
understand
that and try to drop a deuce you can
have a problem me undies is more so than
Tom Hanks in that [ __ ] movie me
undies is also the go for the softest
lounge where is the go to for the
softest lounge where on the planet hang
out and they're super comfy lounge pants
and onesies yes me undies makes me
onesies and there they are incredible me
Andes has a great offer from my
listeners for any first-time purchasers
when you when you when you any money
undies the [ __ ] they're missing words
here when you order any me undies you
get 15% off free ship and get 15% off a
fare the most comfortable undies you
will ever put on to get your 15% off
your first pair free shipping 100%
satisfaction guarantee go to me undies
comm / / that's me undies calm / /
alright that's it it once again lastly
but not leastly truly from the bottom of
my heart congratulation st. Louis you
guys you know without a doubt where you
just were the better team you guys
played [ __ ] amazing hockey and I
really thought it was a great blend of
the old-style hard style of play that I
grew up watching and the new style and
great franchise great [ __ ] fans I'm
sure a lot of bandwagon errs will be
there on Saturday for the parade but all
you old-school guys you know congratula
and women who watch that team
congratulations God knows you [ __ ]
waited longer for it which makes it all
the more sweeter right enjoy this
[ __ ] sad music I wonder if they'll be
sad music I have no idea I don't pick
the music and then we'll have a greatest
hits from a Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday more morning
podcasts when maybe I was a little
happier June 28th was the date 38
the chestplate mommy there's crying at
the weight and everybody's dressed up in
black suits don't win the paid that last
respects to the black truth why the
after job it's the question that we're
under but everyone knows that every day
is a different number so when your time
comes just remember she you'll always
have a place in this world as a
memorable especially loved ones who
passed away back in 92 let's believe
that all the boys in the hoods got you
wherever we go wherever we be we'd be
thinking of how we hung in the club
smoking and drinking
ever missing up on a hood ficus every
day back in the look we had a good fight
everything has changed
and people are looking mommy let's don't
be strange finding New Year's Eve
without your home but ain't much that we
can do except through the rubble to make
sure y'all remember me and believe me it
hurts to see the boy you put bread with
a six feet in the dirt
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the Monday morning podcast from
Monday June 12 2011 how's it going now I
got fuzzing the damn microphone yeah why
why do I keep doing these by myself I
have the star-spangled banner in my
[ __ ] head because the NBA Finals and
the NHL Finals have have never been on
the same night and I've been watching
all of them so that's all I've been
hearing every [ __ ] night Oh Jose and
then when you watch the [ __ ] NHL
Finals you also get oh cannot do
glorious and free
maple syrup and hockey and some [ __ ]
caribou the Alaskan pipeline and [ __ ]
people who think they're from France
just every [ __ ] night and you know
starting to [ __ ] with me can you guys
tell that I have absolutely nothing
prepared for this week nothing funny to
say I don't I got nothing it's a minute
23 and and I'm ready to pull the [ __ ]
plug cuz I got too much [ __ ] to do I'm
actually recording this on a Sunday
afternoon a beautiful beautiful sunday
sunny Sunday afternoon did you go to
church bill oh geez
no I did not although when I was out in
the forest I gotta tell you why not last
week when I thought I was gonna get
eaten by a bear I did pray to a higher
power and I know what a lot of people
right now a lot of you Jesus freaks out
there a lot of you people who were into
the old Jay star probably like yeah see
see you believe you believe I believe in
a higher power yes absolutely but I
don't believe in the in the stories I
don't think he's ever talked to anybody
that's
that's what I believe you know like
today I was in the car and my girl was
bugging me and I said to her you know
what you really making me want to slap
you in the face you notice she's
hell-bent on [ __ ] painting the
goddamn apartment I don't know why all
right and I have to do a benefit tonight
and then I have to go [ __ ] go
straight to the airport and take a
red-eye to Chicago coming in a day early
because I got some friends out there and
therefore they got some ice time
somewhere and you know why not
I'll [ __ ] come in a day early play a
little hockey continue my Peter Pan
lifestyle so of course she's just like I
want to paint the living room we have to
get this done we got a good drop cloth
we got to get some paint
Yatta [ __ ] Jana right so where does
she go I go all right what if where we
going where we going she's like we have
to go to Home Depot all right which I
[ __ ] hate Home Depot
I can't stand it all right with their
900 foot ceilings and their two
employees that they have there and you
finally run into one and it's like you
know first of all you go win the [ __ ]
place and that same feeling I had when I
walked into the forest where I was like
all alone and I don't know what the [ __ ]
was gonna happen that's what you feel
like when you go into these these super
stores as they call them and then you
walk in there when you finally [ __ ]
find somebody you know oh that's not my
department
I just do window shades you know back in
the day when you walked into a hardware
store the [ __ ] person knew the whole
goddamn store first of all cuz it was
only the size of I don't know I don't
know of store and I know all you guys
out there who get on your knees and
slurp the corporate [ __ ] are gonna tell
me well you didn't have as many
selections go [ __ ] yourself
alright swallow the load and kill
yourself because though the old-school
hardware stores they were better
you walk in there was some grumpy guy
there and you'd be like yeah I need a
[ __ ] widget and a [ __ ] shower
curtain ring and he'd look up you know
from some [ __ ] he was whittling on he
tell you exactly where the [ __ ] it was
continue whittling as a corner of his
eye he looked at you as you went in the
wrong to right
people work at Home Depot basically
people who couldn't get a job at the
Apple Store you know they couldn't get
one of those genius t-shirts another get
an orange apron and then you just stand
around you know looking at their nails I
don't know what so anyways we get down
to this [ __ ] place and as we're
driving there all right evidently
whatever paint she wants to get I wasn't
involved in this [ __ ] decision you
know whatever the brand is we're on our
way over there which I really don't have
time to do she goes oh my god I hope
they have you know Eddy Rabinowitz his
eggshell [ __ ] robin egg white or
whatever the [ __ ] she was talking about
and immediately my head I'm like why
didn't you call ahead why didn't you
call ahead so what do you think happened
everybody what do you think happened
when we went into the the [ __ ]
monstrosity that is Home Depot with
their forty thousand [ __ ] different
selections guess what they didn't have
the Eddy Rabinowitz robin egg [ __ ]
blue goddamn coffee cream whatever the
[ __ ] it was called they didn't have it
so immediately I get pissed so she looks
for a silver lining
well Lisa got drop cloths so then we go
to get out of this some [ __ ] I didn't
have [ __ ] time to do anyways and Jen
she wants me to stop McDonald to go get
a [ __ ] the lemonade frozen frisbee or
whatever the [ __ ] drink they have there
and I'm like no I'm not doing it I don't
have time so of course she starts
pouting so what do I do I give in like
uh I give in you know and I was sitting
there when the goddamn [ __ ] line and
you McDonough's was hilarious and
evidently they're trying to go healthy I
think the Biggest Loser is really
starting to [ __ ] with these fast-food
places because all these fatties are
finally realizing oh really I can't have
three seven thousand calorie triple
double cheeseburger
with bacon on it evidently that's the
reason why I have this slab of [ __ ]
that's covering my knees at this point
forget about my genitalia I think the
the biggest loser I think that they've
actually had an effect cuz I went there
and you could actually get like a
Waldorf salad or some [ __ ] some salad
with like an apple and which was
hilarious because you know it sucks it's
still somehow and then they had like
some low-fat yogurt with it is long as
McDonald's is doing it it's somehow
still gonna come out to about 9,000
calories so what the [ __ ] was my point
here was talking about slapping her in
the face oh that's what I said am i
slapping the face ah Jesus Christ I was
going somewhere with this the [ __ ] was I
talking about how did I get into this
talking about going in the woods ah
Jesus you know I don't even remember I'm
such a long-winded jackass what the [ __ ]
was they talking about there's something
about slap her in the face and then I
didn't do that and that tied into some
other [ __ ] that I can't [ __ ] remember
[ __ ] why do I try
oh it's talking about Church right why I
don't believe oh that's right that's
right Church there we go we're back on
track everybody back on track so I said
I'm gonna really feel like slapping you
in the face this is when we were on the
way of the McDonald's and she goes you
know obviously looking at him looking at
me like don't do that so I go you know
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna slap Jesus
instead because she's into rosaries you
know and she has it hanging from the
[ __ ] rearview mirror of our stupid
Prius so I'm gonna I'm gonna slap Jesus
anyway so uh he's sitting there on the
cross of course always in that moment
look what I did for you right so I just
[ __ ] slap him right on the cross and
he flies back and forth so she starts
giving me [ __ ] don't slap Jesus right
and uh yeah that's what I just kind of
said you know do you really think that
this happened that God you know took out
his giant [ __ ] higher being dick came
into this [ __ ] petri dish the size of
a jacuz
right and then took out some sort of
syringe and artificially inseminated
what's-her-face there Jennifer was it
was that his mom's name all right
do you really think that happened it
didn't it didn't happen am i saying
there's not a higher power no I'm not
saying that I'm just saying all these
[ __ ] stories that they're telling you
are them they're made up this guy did
you know he came out of a womb that was
never in banged and then he died for you
and the only way to get into heaven is
if you do what we say and give us some
money I mean how [ __ ] dumb are you if
you go into that [ __ ] I can't help you I
can't [ __ ] help you but if you want
to talk about a higher power I
definitely believe in that [ __ ] but none
of us know what it is I don't believe I
don't I don't [ __ ] know I don't know
where you go I don't know what happens
but neither does anybody else
because you read it in a book what
happens when you die who wrote it who
exactly wrote it how dumb do I sound
right now to all you Jesus freaks y'all
rolling your eyes as you write with your
feathered pen to punish yourself for
some [ __ ] that you did here's
something for you I don't believe in
ghosts either all right we're just gonna
go right down the line of [ __ ] that I
don't believe and I don't believe in
Jesus and I don't believe in ghosts but
I gotta admit this some sort of
paranormal [ __ ] been going on in my
[ __ ] apartment lately all right we
went on vacation we came back and all
our Forks are missing except for two of
them you know and on two different
occasions I've been playing guitar I get
up out of my little [ __ ] playpen area
slash office and I walk in to talk to
Nia and then I come back in my settings
are different on my [ __ ] amp so I
think considering that the go
just stole my Forks and is [ __ ] with
my apps there's only one logical
conclusion that this spirit died at a
Scorpion's concert that's what happened
all right and the only heavy metal fans
got that remember that that song there's
no one like you and the guy had the
forks in his eyes remember that [ __ ] I
think that that's what's going on so I'm
gonna be on the next season of ghost
hunters and I'm gonna sit in there with
some douchebag with the video camera
yelling at the ghost you have exactly
four minutes to show yourself
you ever see that have I talked about
that how ridiculous that [ __ ] show
ghost hunters is those [ __ ] idiots
sit around yelling at the gay oasis for
some how first of all they always know
the ghost name and they'll just be
sitting there yelling at the ghost like
threatening it like threatening this
spirit that evidently is is hanging out
in a kitchen for all eternity you know
right what do you think Maggie's
thinking will do it I don't give a [ __ ]
this is the most entertaining [ __ ] ever
sitting here frustrating you guys a
flicky in the air my little ghost
fingers on the way up you guys believe
in ghosts II believe in that [ __ ] I was
actually watching uh some [ __ ]
channel I can't remember the names of
anything it's called like Paola or
something Pirelli that's a tire okay
they have all these [ __ ] unplugged
sets by these bands that's my computer
making all that noise and I was watching
one uh you know when you get to be old
like me you you just lose touch with
modern music but there's bands that you
just you keep hearing their Fall Out Boy
and I'll [ __ ] you while you young people
oh my god that's like thirty thousand
whatever I don't give a [ __ ] I'm just
saying they blend in so one of them was
my morning jacket
all right now when I grew up no one
would name a band My Morning Jacket all
right you name it something that had to
do with Satan or else I wasn't gonna
listen to it so whenever I heard My
Morning Jacket that just sounded like
you know it was gonna be like that Jack
Johnson's kind of stuff you know that
[ __ ] that like women and hippies like so
I never listen to it you know I just
thought it was gonna be more like that
Fall Out Boy like that whining crying
remember like the last 10 years that emo
[ __ ] where was that song that that I
made fun of that one week we will be big
does that sound like you're gonna win
anything that sounds like you're already
lost and you're walking home crying to
your mom and you just talking [ __ ] cuz
you're too [ __ ] embarrassed knowing
you lost so I assumed that they would
kind of like that and I don't know man I
watched if their unplugs that they were
[ __ ] unbelievable and I want to
download some of this [ __ ] all right
legally so let me know how's the latest
album because it was somebody else who
was on likely Keely was on before it and
I watched her [ __ ] and I loved it and
then I listened to that on iTunes and I
was like ah via unplug [ __ ] sounded way
better her [ __ ] was like singing through
all this distortion stuff I which I
can't stand after a while you know it's
like [ __ ] just sing the goddamn song
okay stop sounding like you [ __ ] I'm
listening to it three floors above you
you know if you're gonna do some [ __ ]
like that do it the way Jimmy Page did
it and I felt like I was an on acid you
know how he used to do that [ __ ] and he
and he would have it you back in the day
you would listen to albums on headphones
and bands knew it and they knew you were
on drugs and they used to try to enhance
the experience that's how great rock
used to be okay that's how into drugs
they were they knew you were on drugs so
they would make album and they were on
drugs and they would make album
that would make being on drugs feel
better and they used to do [ __ ] where
they would they would whatever they'd
have some sort of some sort of effect
going on and they would they would make
it go from the left side to the right
side just your speakers but when you had
headphones on it felt like it passed
through your goddamn head it's
tremendous I don't know I don't know
what the [ __ ] they do they yell into a
bullhorn throughout the whole [ __ ]
concert into a microphone like that
that's the best you can do who does that
[ __ ] you know does that all the time is
that guy Scott Weiland said his name the
guy from STP Velvet Revolver he's big
into that singing through the [ __ ]
bullhorn as he walks around in his Nazi
supermodel outfit anyways this is the
Monday morning podcast everybody are you
a new listener I hope you are I hope we
continue to grow this podcast I do one
of these every goddamn week and people
send me questions they ask for advice
they send me lists of underrated
overrated we talk about You Tube [ __ ]
videos that we like I curse a lot
because I don't read I'm not intelligent
all right speaking of YouTube videos
which I keep forgetting to talk about I
got a bunch at this point here's one you
gotta watch and these are all by the way
all of these can be viewed exclusively
at the mmm podcast com
first off I did another tour of you know
those videos I make where I do like the
tours of Los Angeles and show you
different parts of LA I'm actually I did
one in New York City and we just put
that up so we'll have that on the mmm
podcast page and do you remember when I
was sick a few weeks ago and I felt like
[ __ ] and all that this video was shot
the day that I was getting sick notice
when I'm on the subway when I'm walking
down there look at the the flop sweat on
my giant forehead as I'm starting to get
sick we got that and here's a video that
his sense blown up which pisses me off
because I've been meaning to talk about
this one for a month there's one a video
called
and escapes I don't know if I talked I
don't think I talked about this one yet
it's basically some kid in an Astros
game he jumps out of the stands runs
across right field gives a great head
fake to a security guard breaks his
ankles he goes up and over the wall he
just and just [ __ ] amazing
he basically climbs up the stadium and
runs out the back of it and as far as I
know he got away and I would love a lot
of Europeans to watch this who think
every American's a fat [ __ ] you should
see this guy this guy does like but a
good four or five pull-ups and climbs up
out of a stadium from basically
centerfield it's amazing so definitely
check that one out there's another good
one out there that I was watching called
it's basically how to how to talk to
cops
and this one's funny because you could
if the people who actually are doing it
are actually complete dirtbags but they
know their rights probably because
they've been getting arrested their
entire life and it's really fascinating
I saw this video a long time ago about
how many rights you give up when the
cops pull you over simply because you
don't you don't know the law and they
just ask you questions like in this
video the guy goes because the guy was
videotaping the cop he comes over he
goes what do you videotape me for he
goes can I see that camera please
now most people 90% of people be like
yes officer here you go cuz you're
you're you don't wanna get arrested this
guy was like no then the cop goes why
can't and the Camry goes ah cuz it's
mine and you need a search warrant
he just started rattling off this [ __ ]
and the cops just like half [ __ ] he
knows the rule I don't feel I was needs
a search warrant but you know he needs
probable cause I'm videotaping it's
illegal it's not illegal to videotape
and he just he stone walls the guy and
he goes and i'm on my property you're
actually on my property get off my
property please and every time he says
this [ __ ] you like oh my god he comes
the beat down but it never [ __ ]
happens but who's kidding oh the only
reason why it goes down like this is
because there's witnesses there's too
many people standing around because if
this guy tried this [ __ ] in the middle
no we're with a cop the the video camera
would be up his ass and he would also be
facing some sort of charges of
assaulting the police officer because
the police officer sprained one of his
fingers when he shoved the camera up his
ass
at least that's been my experience um
what are the YouTube videos let me make
sure I read all of these let me show you
make sure you know these before I move
on to the next topics here Oh for
Christ's sake with a [ __ ] the other
YouTube videos oh this is a good one I
think we actually did this one a long
time ago
boyfriend [ __ ] you you ever do that [ __ ]
we hit on a girlfriend she lets you hit
on a girlfriend you hit on some girl and
she lets you do it for 10 minutes and
then brings up her boyfriend this guy
does the reaction that you want to do
it's called boyfriend [ __ ] you and then
we got some music ones here crossroads
festival Steve Winwood Eric Clapton
Steve Jordan my favorite drummer and
Derek Trucks what else we got here Mark
Knopfler I've even looked at these up
and so goddamn busy we got some music
ones this week and what the [ __ ] was the
other one oh I know what I wanted to
talk about you guys do you guys do you
have a guilty pleasure movie that you
watch that you would be unbelievably
embarrassed that other people would know
that anytime you see it you definitely
watch it this is mine it's actually
called the goodbye girl which is
arguably one of the gayest [ __ ]
movies of all time alright but what I
love about it the reason why I like it
is cuz it's Richard Dreyfuss his first
big role and I'm a big Richard Dreyfuss
fan and I just love it cuz you see a guy
seizing the opportunity that he's got
this role and he just he just goes all
out it's a total [ __ ] chick flick or
whatever but I don't know he's always
funny to me and the amount of [ __ ] that
he has to do in the movie that I would
be embarrassed to do when he pulls it
off is why I always end up watching the
movie but and I way I never watch it
from beginning to end I always catch it
at some point plus I'm a sucker for any
movie that's shot in New York and I get
to see what New York
used to look like so that's another
reason why I love watching that movie
and it's just a great movie on a lot of
different levels there's another level
where the only people of color in that
movie play muggers like you really see
what the [ __ ] Spike Lee is complaining
about when you [ __ ] see it's like
it's so like how white they make New
York is unbelievable this just
wall-to-wall [ __ ] everybody's white and
then at one point though gets a grocery
stolen so Richard Dreyfuss runs after
this carload of people and out of the
car jumps like two Puerto Ricans and a
black guy and they got [ __ ] afros and
knives all of a sudden it turns into
death wish this chick flick for like
half a second it's completely
unnecessary in the plot in the movie
other than to just remind white people
to be racist but that's not what I
wanted to talk about in the movie what
really interests me in that movie is I
mentioned a zillion times as I Drive a
Toyota Prius and when I drive it
properly and I'm not slamming on the
brakes and stop it on the gas I can get
41 miles per gallon okay which is
supposed to be good because a lot of
[ __ ] gets 2325 now I've maintained for a
while now that cars in the 70s used to
get like 33 35 miles of [ __ ] gallon
and that's goddamn almost you know 35 40
years ago in this movie this chick flick
the goodbye girl the chick that Dreyfuss
is falling for she's actually you guys
ever go to a car show you know where
they show all the whatever this year
they coming up in October they'll start
having the car show and they have all
the 2012 models that are coming out and
speaking of models that have these
broads standing next to him at least
they did back in the day unless they
consider it too sexist they'd have
good-looking women standing there
talking about the cars so anyways her
character does that in this movie and
it's like it's like 76 1977 something
like that and she's standing in front of
this Subaru talking about the car and
says it gets 39
9 miles per gallon alright see this is
why I don't believe in [ __ ] I don't
believe in [ __ ] anything this is why
everybody thinks I'll you're paranoid
you're a [ __ ] conspiracy that's it
[ __ ] right there 39 miles per gallon
on this [ __ ] all-wheel drive Subaru
those things back they weren't oh yeah
four-wheel drive Subaru got 39 miles per
gallon that was their claim okay
that's nineteen [ __ ] 76 or 77 you're
telling me in 35 years the best we've
been able to do is get me an extra two
miles per gallon on a [ __ ] hybrid
it's complete [ __ ] I think there's
plenty of [ __ ] oil and it said the
whole thing's for sure do you know what
time I was riding and I was riding in a
cab in New York City and this
pakistanian dude was driving it you know
surprise surprise
and I was talking to him about I always
like I love talking to people who don't
live here you know who initially didn't
live here and now live here just getting
their whole viewpoint on [ __ ] whether I
agree with it or not it's just
interesting to me so I was talking to
him this is the first time the gas
prices were going through the [ __ ]
roof and he says to me he goes do you
know a Toyota Camry in this country gets
like whatever the [ __ ] it was at the
time 23 25 miles per gallon he goes do
you know in my country it gets like 38
39 miles per gallon or like 40 something
ridiculous he goes do you know why that
is and I said no and he goes because we
can't afford a car that gets 23 to 25
miles per gallon because I guess where
they live whatever the [ __ ] gas
prices are whatever their [ __ ]
economy is they can't afford a car that
gets that amount of mile so they just
adjust the goddamn engine so what I'm
saying people is it's all [ __ ] I
don't know where I'm going with this
stuff and I don't know who to complain
to what about all those grease monkeys
out there you sit there and you watch
these [ __ ] shows on TV where they
they do like a build they'll have some
car you know like we're at eight today
we're
you're not gonna believe what we're
gonna do we got a 1972 you [ __ ] GMC
Willie's garbage truck and we're gonna
combine that with a 1975 Porsche 911
it's all gonna look [ __ ] sweet and
they somehow do it the [ __ ] car runs
and it [ __ ] got like nine wheels and
it goes flying down the street and got a
fish tank in the back right why don't
they use that talent to [ __ ] with the
engine and get it to get it to make like
you know like a hundred miles per gallon
or any of my podcast listeners out there
do you know how to do that [ __ ] is it
that [ __ ] hard isn't it just a couple
of twists of the screwdriver on a
carburetor do they have carburetors
anymore
yeah Christ I don't what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about let's let's plow ahead
everybody he's getting into conspiracy
theory oh gee he alright let's go with
advice here you know like always
somebody sent me one and I can't
remember where the [ __ ] I put it but
some lady came over here from England
and she lives just north of New York
City and she loves living here she loves
the excess of America is what she said
but her husband she said is driving him
nuts because he's an environmentalist
and he is taking the environmentalist
stance to the point that he won't flush
the toilet when he just takes a piss so
she goes walking into the loo as she
calls it and he's got his [ __ ] piss
in there and she's like well what do I
do about this this is what you do lady
you gotta tell just put a [ __ ] brick
or a stone in the back of your toilet so
you won't use as much water and tell the
dude to flush the goddamn toilet okay
just tell him to flush the toilet I'm
all for trying to conserve but flush the
[ __ ] toilet
alright and furthermore I don't like
your attitude though cuz she did the
classic where you know he's doing all
this other stuff too for the environment
like it's gonna matter I hate people who
got that defeatist attitude that's not
gonna [ __ ] matter you know like when
you vote for a Ron Paul and they tell
you that you wasted your vote by voting
for somebody who's actually being honest
whether you agree with them or not like
that's a wasted
I'll really waste it's a wasted vote to
vote for that guy to try encourage more
people like that who don't give a [ __ ]
to run for office Dodie he's not gonna
win so that that's why you vote you vote
cuz you want to vote for a winner ah
Jesus that's depressing speaking of
[ __ ] depressing the [ __ ] Stanley
Cup Finals this year I can anybody
figure it out I think this has been one
of the most torturous finals for fans on
both sides
God knows those Canuck [ __ ] wouldn't
admit to it because now they're up three
games to two but you can't tell me
during Game three and four you weren't
like what the [ __ ] happened to my team
why are they playing like a bunch of
[ __ ] and allowing themselves to be
pushed all over the ice that's what's
happened every home game the visiting
team just gets smashed in the mouth and
does nothing about it it's [ __ ]
driving me nuts
alright I'm getting sick II you [ __ ]
Canuck fans talking [ __ ] like your team
is [ __ ] superior you've won 3-1 gold
games the twins
what have they done they haven't done
[ __ ] what is Ryan Kesler done [ __ ] he's
done nothing what about that [ __ ]
that goddamn Luongo with his sad basset
hound eyes behind his goalie mask you
bunch of punks I actually liked your
[ __ ] team until we played you guys
and the amount of [ __ ] you guys have
been talking I actually used to like
your [ __ ] team I would have rooted
for the if the Bruins weren't in I would
have ruin it for the Canucks cuz they
never won one but their fans are such
[ __ ] Oh at their stupid hankies that
they have during the goddamn game the
only people who should do that are
Pittsburgh Steeler fans they came up
with it it was the Terrible Towel anyone
else who does it it's [ __ ] gay and I
can't wait for the Bruins to win Game
six in Game seven so you [ __ ] [ __ ]
are crying and you're goddamn hankies
Jesus Christ this is the thing though I
actually think they're a great team
and they got a tremendous amount of
talent on there but those [ __ ]
are the cheapest sons of [ __ ] I've
ever seen in my life
I don't mind the hits I don't mind that
[ __ ] you know it happens all right
but the [ __ ] the diving and the
flopping hey I asked this the other day
I was on TSN which is the ESPN up in
Canada I called in and I asked this can
some hockey fan please explain to me all
right and one of the games the last game
actually gained five all right they're
right that lining up for a face-off and
burrows is right next to Lucic so what
he does is he puts his leg in front of
leaches stick and then just does a
pratfall and acts like he trips okay now
I would think that either he'd get two
minutes for diving or they would call
Lucic for tripping because they didn't
realize that you know that they got
faked out but for some reason Lucic got
two minutes for tripping and Burroughs
got two minutes for embellishment or
something stupid like that I don't get
that it's like he either [ __ ] trip
the guy or he didn't what does that
penalty mean like okay he trips you
buddy didn't trip you that bad I don't
know I've had it the [ __ ] goddamn
twins Jesus Christ did that did flopping
all over the [ __ ] ice that's how you
want to win a Cup Vancouver that's how
you want to do it by pretending you got
hurt [ __ ] shameless just as shameless
[ __ ] hockey team I got no I have
absolutely no [ __ ] respect for Mike
I've lost all [ __ ] respect for that
goddamn team and I can't believe it
there's no [ __ ] reason for them to be
doing that [ __ ] they got enough weapons
they sort of have a good goaltender and
they're a great physical team why do you
got to play like [ __ ]
you know why is that what you guys do
out there in Vancouver is that what you
do when you're not going out on a
[ __ ] whale watch and listening to you
Eurotrash music with your awful tight
clothes that you wear up there I've been
to
Coover for about 20 minutes beautiful
scenery if you're not looking at the
people I can't wait to play Tampa or
Vancouver just for the fan that actually
takes this [ __ ] seriously
anyways plowing ahead plowing ahead
speaking of speaking of what the [ __ ]
was I talking about Oh gay and all that
type of stuff a certain comedian got
into a bunch of trouble for a bunch of
stuff he said during uh during a during
a stand-up performance and people got
offended and this really bugged me I was
watching a news program I was watching a
program that involved the news and this
dude came on and the comedian apologized
and they asked him what he thought he go
and the guy was just like well you know
I think the apology was good but I don't
think it's enough I think he should
donate some money to the [ __ ] blah
blah blah blah blah and it just it just
killed the whole [ __ ] thing for me it
killed the outrage I should really just
look at the guy at that it's like really
at the end of it all you want to do is
just get some [ __ ] money out of the
guy you know I don't understand that I
really don't you know somebody does
something and then they apologize that
should be enough you got that's not
enough you got to take the money out of
his [ __ ] wallet you know so if that's
the case then you really don't give a
[ __ ] about the apology you just wanted
so if you just using as and as an excuse
to get some [ __ ] money right do they
make any [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't know I'm
basically judging the entire topic
because of that one douche I saw on TV
alright let's plow ahead here before I
have to [ __ ] apologize to somebody of
people of Vancouver do you think that is
his apology that he made fun of your
white belts and white shoes your herb
Harlech Eurotrash way of [ __ ]
dressing at your dance clubs the fact
that he apologized was that enough um I
don't think it's quite enough I think he
should make a donation to the Vancouver
mountainous region a go [ __ ] yourselves
alright dear bill I'm I am from Kansas
City and there is currently radio
commercials in which a law officer
allah-allah
office offers their services exclusively
for women going through a divorce of
course they do there's a ton of money
involved there they talk about how they
review all of the husband's finances and
insure the woman will receive the
maximum amount the law will allow and
then he writes in capital letters what
the [ __ ] are there any law offices that
offer services exclusively for men I
doubted if there were I would imagine
there would be a huge protest from
feminists all across the US I know
you've addressed this hundreds of times
over but why is it okay to completely
[ __ ] a man over this commercial
insinuates the man is already in the
wrong this is absolute [ __ ] dude yet
preach on this guy's speak in the gospel
here anyways wanted to share this with
you as this is just another example of
man bashing commercials that just piss
me off alright let's let's let's review
this yeah okay first of all you can't
get mad at the lawyers because they're
just going where the money is and and as
you as you as you say that if it was the
opposite way that there would be
feminist groups protesting alright that
therein lies the [ __ ] problem until
men actually get together and start
protesting that type of [ __ ] which I
would absolutely love to be a part of on
any [ __ ] level I would love to see
that happen but we're guys we don't do
that [ __ ] once we get you get punched in
the face yeah [ __ ] you you get up and
you walk away like you can't do that
like well yeah there should be guys
protesting it I think that would be
[ __ ] hilarious
that's absolutely terrifying that's one
of nine million reasons why I never got
[ __ ] married
that is just un-fuckin'-believable you
know I'll tell you what kills me is most
women who would watch that they always
say the same thing when you like you'll
say to them I can you believe that [ __ ]
when they always say that st. yeah
that's right that's right yeah that's
what you get that's what you get uh big
stupid face what the [ __ ] have you ever
done that that's my whole my whole thing
with that it's just uh I don't know you
get married you just better pray to God
it [ __ ] works out there's a guy
that's all you have and the amount of
power it's not it's not a balanced
relationship because of the way that the
divorce laws are it's the second you
know it's like when you're single you
have an unbelievable amount of power as
a guy even if you're in a relationship
because that she can't get to you
legally that's it it's [ __ ] over
you have your [ __ ] and that's it and
you're a guy and you can earn a [ __ ]
living that's it you don't to worry
about [ __ ] then the second you get
married you lose all power because at
any point she can just divorce you and
[ __ ] take you for everything you're
worth everything you work for it's it's
just it's [ __ ] over look at Tiger
Woods Tiger Woods gave his wife a
quarter of a billion dollars she was a
nanny [ __ ] nanny worth what nine
figures for what she had a prenup where
she was only gonna get five million
dollars only five million dollars who
here wouldn't kill for five million
dollars I quit my podcast for a [ __ ]
200 grand you know you find out your
husband's some dog going around cheating
or whatever that's that happens to women
and the guy's a broke-ass son of a [ __ ]
and they're left with nothing so it's
not like women always make out but
here's a situation we find out you have
husbands a dog the marriage is over oh
but I get five million dollars but
that's not enough for the [ __ ] because
she knows he has a billion and she wants
to get as much as
she can't I swear to [ __ ] god I can't
do these topics because it makes you see
red because they're not entitled to it
it's [ __ ] alright if you marry the
greatest golfer of a [ __ ] generation
who's won 14 titles okay and you haven't
even won a game of tiddlywinks on a
professional level you're not entitled
to that money you're not you are legally
but you're not you didn't [ __ ] earn
it you [ __ ] all right there you go bill
get to the core of the hatred all right
number two bill really the [ __ ]
Norwegians get you for multiple gigs and
London gets one night you know how you
know they hate wait a minute do what are
you talking about the Norwegians okay
you're talking about the whole
scandinavian area i'm in a different
country every night i mean i'm in
england one night then Finland and
Norway Norway then Denmark and then
Sweden all right that's totally equal
what are you bitching about not to
mention I already played London and I
the place was three-quarters full I
don't think I need to do a week of dates
there in front of 99 people per show all
right bill really the [ __ ] Norwegians
get you you get you for multiple gigs in
London gets one night and I can't even I
don't know what he says here you know
they hate Merrick you over in Sweden too
right
what is that em er I see you H I'll have
to look that up I don't know what it is
are you trying to fill some sort of urge
to pal around with people who are whiter
than yourself well then look no further
than London sir
they are so white they eat their pizza
with forks and knives you think what you
think because you've been here before
you can just do London in a night and
peace out I use some sort of Anglo
expert now I'm just [ __ ] around glad
you give in London at least one night
look forward to seeing you figures I
discover your comedy after I move out to
Los Angeles well I'm out here in Los
Angeles sir if you'd like to see me I'm
doing a benefit for greg Giraldo 'he's
wife and family at The Wiltern Theatre
what the hell's the [ __ ] date Jesus
they're built how do you not know where
the [ __ ] you're gonna be oh you know
what I know when the [ __ ] it is it's uh
June 29th at The Wiltern Theatre all
right not only can you see me sir you
can see a bunch of other comics doing
that [ __ ] thing alright Jeff Ross
it's gonna be out there slappy white
we're gonna have a bunch of big names
alright what I can see email wasn't done
here by the way that email you read from
that guy who claimed to be French had a
bunch of condescending misinformation in
it right that guy back and tell him he's
a prick just like all the rest of the
French Parisians are otherwise France is
full of garlic eating pseudo moustache
having [ __ ] granted their women are
clean-shaven though too bad the majority
of them look like dudes regardless now
why do you think he's saying all that
[ __ ] people do you know why that is it's
because his country is next to France
nobody likes the country they're next to
right although I do like Canada except
for canady Montreal Canadian fans and
even Vancouver cannot fence with your
hankies ok in your pratfall say one day
all those pratfalls that they do do they
play like Benny Hill music at the
beginning of the shove whenever
Vancouver has a home game when they show
the highlights they go away and they do
show everybody flopping around on the
[ __ ] ice laughing because they're
cheating you got a hell of a team and
you might win the Cup but Jesus Christ
how about next year how about next year
you make some sort of vow that you're
gonna have some sort of [ __ ] code of
honor something
Jesus this whole [ __ ] series which
one of the sin Dean's was it was it that
[ __ ] flopped onto his back and the
ref didn't even call it and when he got
up someone on the Bruins were going it
was going are you ok yeah alright
everything ok oh jesus what a bunch of
[ __ ]
all right overrated underrated for this
week underrated jerking off on the clock
everyone should do this once in their
lifetime you might as well be getting
blown by what by your boss's wife oh
that's [ __ ] hilarious yeah but where
do you do it and then the odds are
getting caught that's that's part of the
excitement [ __ ] weirdo
jerking off at work where exactly a
gherkin off on the clock oh I see so
what now you know what I'm going home
for lunch then you go back and you jerk
off all but non lunch you're not on the
clock sir could you please are could you
please elaborate and let me know where
exactly it is that you jerk off at work
any of my listeners any of you guys you
ever jerk off at work as is this what
the podcast is this what it really has
come down to anybody else have a rub one
out at [ __ ] work and when you do what
do you go obviously the bathroom wow I
mean you're really risking your [ __ ]
career there if you get caught rubbing
one out I'm trying to think of a job
that you could have well you could get
caught rubbing one out at work and
people would laugh it off obviously a
comedian you know if you were rubbing
one out in the greenroom as long as you
sold the room out you know that's the
amazing thing about show business I was
thinking about this [ __ ] the other day
that if you give say you killed somebody
you committed murder but it was judged a
crime of passion you know you lost your
[ __ ] you [ __ ] killed somebody so
you're going to jail for at least 15
years
okay so 15 years 17 years you get out
were you gonna get a goddamn job okay
other than just continuing to be a
criminal you know selling drugs or some
[ __ ] you know there's only two places
that you I think that you can get a job
you can become like a car salesman
because they don't give a [ __ ] you know
or you can get into show business
it's [ __ ] amazing you can coach you
can walk right out of prison if anybody
is in prison listening to this [ __ ]
you know if you have these privileges
you can get out of prison you know after
doing 17 years and then they hand you
your [ __ ] Z cavariccis that you wore
when you walked into prison back in
[ __ ] 1993 with your goatee and I
can't believe Kurt Cobain just killed
himself t-shirt right within a week you
could sign up right the first [ __ ]
day you go out sign up for an open mic
you could write five minutes material
and you could be on stage telling jokes
within a [ __ ] week and not only could
you be not only would you be accepted
when other comedians found out that you
murdered somebody
their reaction wouldn't be like holy
[ __ ] you're a piece of [ __ ] they would
just be like dude dude you should talk
about that on stage that that could be
your hook man you go up in your orange
jumpsuit all right you let people know
that you killed somebody and then first
of all no one's gonna [ __ ] heckle you
and then he can intimidate the crowd
that if they don't laugh at your jokes
you're gonna go you [ __ ] do it again
you know I was actually talking to
somebody about that the other day about
you know that's that's a conversation
that guys have a lot about do you think
you could survive if you went to prison
and I was talking to Keith Robinson
about this [ __ ] and I was telling him
that I would go into prison and I would
immediately join the Aryan Nation
immediately I would I would have a Bic
pen out if I smuggled it in I would now
I would be drawing the swastika between
my eyes not because I believe in that
[ __ ] I just don't want to get raped so I
would be drawing that in on the bus ride
into the prison and I told Keith you
know no offense that if I did see him in
prison I would have to call him the
n-word I just would just you know not
out of some racist [ __ ] I just I would
not want I just don't want to get raped
and I have to bond with the [ __ ] the
psycho
this psycho [ __ ] uh what do you call
him we call those guys the white
supremists and I'd have to sit there
listening to their awful music remember
that from American History X remember
that fatty was in the van singing the
white man Oh would I be counting down
the [ __ ] days Jesus Christ but you'd
have to do it you'd have to do it you'd
have to become a full-on [ __ ] Aryan
maniac what are your what are your
options you know I mean I'm all for you
know not being racist 100 percent all
about it I think it's ignorant and all
that type of [ __ ] but I draw the line at
getting [ __ ] in the ass all right [ __ ]
that [ __ ] that noise son I'll say some
[ __ ] that'll make [ __ ] Charles Manson
blush well maybe that's the guy I'd
knock out come walking up to him with
his vampire fingernails and just [ __ ]
slap the beard right off his face maybe
that would prevent it I don't know if
anybody's ever been to prison what
exactly someone like me right before I
commit to going in there and just
shaving my head and acting like I'm part
of the Aryan Nation because that's the
only way I see you know getting out of
it if anybody who's been listening to
this [ __ ] has been to prison how does a
Ron Howard Ralph Malph looking jackass
like myself who hasn't had a fist fight
since junior high outside of his family
how do you survive how do you do it
that's the only option I can think I got
to go in there and I got a hang Jesus
then I'd have to get a bunch of awful
tattoos oh Jesus Christ that was I
probably just kill myself
that's what I was joking about but then
I wouldn't have the nerve to do it and
then I'd get raped and then I'd be
thinking as I was getting raped going
I should have done it earlier cuz now I
gotta kill myself it's [ __ ] unreal so
anyways whenever you see these [ __ ]
people when they I remember a long time
ago there was some like some kid in New
York City there was this classic case
where he he killed his girlfriend and he
said that they were having rough sex and
it got out of control right which is
complete horseshit he killed her right
but that's what he said so anyways he
ended up doing all of his time because
he kept getting busted for [ __ ] so when
he was getting in prison so like they
were talking about they were talking
about him getting out I remember he was
getting out there like someone so was
getting out of prison the you know the
famous case bla bla bla bla bla and
evidently he was quite a busy man
when he was in prison and they start
giving him [ __ ] going like he got busted
on numerous occasions for selling drugs
he got into a couple of altercations
with the guards and other inmates and
they're talking about him like he should
have been there coloring it's like no he
was doing what he had to do so he didn't
become somebody's girlfriend I hate when
people do that when they talk about
people not behaving nicely in prison as
if that's a place where that is an
option I saw a guy one time he was
saying that I'm one of those prison
shows he was talking about how whenever
this they're coming into your cell they
give you the option where you you put
your you put you back to the door and
then they reach it and they handcuff you
and he's saying he can't do that he goes
your options are basically you back up
like a [ __ ] to the door and then all
the other inmates look at you like
you're a [ __ ] or you fight them so what
are you supposed to do you got you so
you basically have to take a beat-down
from these [ __ ] officers who are
dressed like Robocop so that they don't
rape you because you're bad exist it's
[ __ ] horrific it's absolutely
horrific and the fact that I've blown
off jury duty for the last [ __ ] 16
months
speaking of being racist that's one that
people always say like to get out of
jury duty like they always just go in
there you just go in there and you just
say a bunch of racist [ __ ] I love when
people like they think that that's how
you do it it's like you know yeah or you
could just ignore it when it comes in
the mail you just don't respond to it
you could always do that as opposed to
going down to the courthouse and just
saying racist [ __ ] you know you're
you're overthinking it
all right where the hell am i overrated
American football even the name is
inaccurate Mexicans don't play it
Brazilians don't Argentine teens don't
hmm Canadians don't play it much no they
do play it they have a whole league you
[ __ ] you just too dumb to name another
country how about Venezuela dumb [ __ ]
and here's a crucial bit nor does the
rest of the world this is a game where
the Super Bowl is played only by
American teams yet they call themselves
world champs dude this is one of the
oldest arguments I've ever heard even
the World Cup events of hockey rugby and
rock-paper-scissors yes that's a real
event invite competitors from more than
two nations it's one of these few sports
whose All American heroes from Joe
Montana to Walter Payton were a bunch of
guys who only played against their
compatriots well you know what if you
[ __ ] want to put together a team and
try and join the NFL I mean they play a
game in London every year trying to get
you guys interested in it you're not
interested in the [ __ ] game and I
guarantee whatever [ __ ] team you put
together will kick the [ __ ] out of you
just like we have in basketball our
[ __ ] sport you can't the [ __ ] do you
get off talking about football is you
know what football is football is the
correction to soccer see Americans were
smart enough to realize how goddamn
boring your your [ __ ] sport is and
you want to talk about a bunch of people
diving I actually I'm gonna take it back
I'm gonna actually apologize to the
Vancouver Canucks for suggesting that
they were diving on
an insane level okay professional soccer
players take it to an entirely different
level all right every time somebody
comes up and barely touches you you act
like you just got thrown out of a
[ __ ] car and you sit there with your
scarves singing songs cuz you're so
goddamn bored waiting for a [ __ ] goal
to be scored what would happen if you
actually picked the goddamn ball up and
ran with it
it'd be exciting like rugby rugby is
exciting as opposed to soccer or
football whatever the [ __ ] you call it
and I know what you're saying like yeah
but in rugby they're not [ __ ] they
don't wear helmets
yeah they don't hit each other as hard
either I've watched it I've watched both
I think they're both awesome sports to
watch both of them make me cringe but
the American game is way faster and way
more [ __ ] violent it just is alright
our football players are actually dying
in their 50s and donating their brains
to science and they're finding that they
have this guys have died in their 40s
that that whatever the [ __ ] they have on
their brain they don't see in the
average they see it basically with
people who die of Alzheimer's in their
80s okay
people get paralyzed playing our game
alright if you don't like our game you
know what it is the rest of the world
you know I this is what I think it is
this is what I think your big [ __ ]
problem with America is is that you just
like a lot of our [ __ ] you like our
music you like our clothes you like a
lot of our culture and it kills you that
we don't pay attention to your [ __ ] you
want our [ __ ] approval on some
goddamn level don't roll your [ __ ]
eyes at me
you do the [ __ ] are you doing listening
to this podcast this is an American
podcast sir what is your [ __ ] other
than our foreign policy which I totally
[ __ ] understand what is it you know
because all the [ __ ] I just said about
soccer I actually really enjoy the
Premier League I really enjoy that and I
just think it's cool that you go there
and you sing songs and you drink [ __ ]
beer with your red fat faces I think
that's a good thing
you know I actually I respect the
[ __ ] game here you come over here
talking about [ __ ] uh how the [ __ ] is
American football overrated you never
even said why it was overrated it is
American footballs but United States is
in the Americas you dumb [ __ ] what are
we supposed to call it Asian football
you know what you're a goddamn dummy
aren't you are you on the dole is that
what you guys call welfare over there
what do you see Mexicans don't play it
Brazilians don't play it our teachers
don't yeah yeah they don't they don't
what because they don't play it we
shouldn't play it and it shouldn't be
called American football even though
we're in America explain yourself sir
I'm tired of that whole [ __ ] thing oh
then he goes well let me digress it's a
great game if you love commercial breaks
well what about your [ __ ] game your
game needs a commercial break you know
what you know what [ __ ] soccer needs
needs a goddamn it means like a halftime
show that's being played the entire time
if you get bored one-nil we're into the
penalty time and everybody's sitting
there whistling in the crowd you did
something bad here you got a yellow card
oh he took out the red card Jesus a
bunch of guys running around in shorts
anyways advice hey Bill loved the
podcast most guys would probably write
in and howl and ask how to get their
girlfriend to do anal well I've got a
question that's a little more practical
a girl that I'm seeing absolutely loves
anal oh Jesus
yeah that you know something that that's
disgusting
all right I'm just gonna say that right
off the bat that it's just [ __ ] gross
that's something that for some reason
became a big thing and porn for a while
and you know all I'm gonna say is this
then try to keep it clean here
you participate in that act long enough
you're gonna realize why at some point
someday one time you're gonna realize
why you should never stick your pee-pee
in there all right without getting gross
okay she insists on it every time we
have sex yeah the other day after we got
back from a road trip that involved way
too much gas station food up here we go
here we go she was having an abnormal
amount of gas all right I'm gonna pause
here and give you guys a chance to just
kind of walk away from your little
recording devices so you don't have to
listen to the rest of this here we go
well she eventually got up off the couch
ran to the bathroom and yelled I just
[ __ ] my pants she was really cool about
it well Jesus I mean I mean how cool can
you be about it other than just being
honest but she's concerned about the
effects of constantly having things
shoved up her ass yeah well she should
be she just turned 30 and has only
started doing anal on a consistent basis
for the last few years I was wondering
if you could what why are you bringing
my girl into this get her to invite some
of her friends over and then ramli
randomly asked her friends which ones do
anal
on a consistent basis and whether or not
they have problems [ __ ] themselves
thanks for the help
yeah she didn't I don't know she didn't
[ __ ] herself because of the sex you
haven't she [ __ ] herself because you ate
at a gas station I think but I can't
tell you that I you know yeah yeah yeah
I don't know you know I'm not a doctor
I'm not into doing that to female and
you know let's see it's a very soft
membrane in there you're dealing with
you're dealing with a bunch of issues
there buddy
bunch of [ __ ] issue there's no reason
to do it
um what I would tell her is like yeah
that's why you should
yourself so you can get out of having to
do that to her
you don't want to do that to the person
you love who yeah that's the mother your
kids someday you know what wouldn't with
that I think it's about time to end this
[ __ ] podcast let's go with one more
of these Hey hello bill I'm 18 years old
I've been with my girlfriend for three
years and honestly I'm tired of [ __ ]
her the relationship is fine me and her
get along great but I feel like the
excitement and the lust is gone this is
becoming a problem as making it really
difficult not to cheat I'm guessing at
some point you've had the same problem I
just want to know is this going to
happen with every long-term relationship
I feel like I'm living the life of a
middle-aged married man and I already
but I don't want it to end it as me and
her get along fine and also I just also
just to add we've recently tried
basically every sexually and we've
everything sexually and we've easily had
sex more than 500 times so there's no
way to really spice things up any more
Thanks yes I really think you would blow
up over here in England if you got your
specials on TV over here you seem to tap
into the British humour the podcast is
great man yeah dude you know what if
anybody knows anybody over there a TV I
would love to get my specials on over
there I think I have to do local TV over
there I should probably try and do that
do a local TV show over there that's a
great [ __ ] idea what the hell was
your question sir there is no way to
spice it up after you've banged up 500
times you just better hope that you love
her in the end sexual happened less
frequent and it's just how it is
it's just how it is but then you know if
you really love this girl and you dumper
you're gonna you're gonna be sad and be
thinking about her as you're banging
this new girl who you're going to be
excited about [ __ ] probably about 40
times and then you're gonna be right
back to it so that's why they say it's
not the be-all end-all I don't know what
to tell you you know I don't know I want
you go down the costume store store and
dress up like a [ __ ] milkman why
don't you start with that
I don't know what to tell you I don't
know what to tell you dude
yeah it's [ __ ] brutal it happens it
happens to everybody sorry to end on a
[ __ ] downer there uh anyways let's
let's go up let's go up here I'm gonna
be at the Chicago theater with one of
the anti social network tour dates with
Jim Breuer Dave Attell and the
wonderfully talented Jimmy Norton June
15th Wednesday June 15th I'm gonna be
out there at the Chicago theater there's
still some tickets left very few please
get off your ass come on down come on
see the show you're getting four for the
price of one
and as I'm far as I'm concerned for the
best goddamn comics you're gonna see out
today all right look at me talking a
little bit of [ __ ] and later on this
month I'm gonna be at The Wiltern
theater for the greg Giraldo benefit
here in Los Angeles
please please please buy some tickets
all the proceeds go to his his widow and
his wonderful kids and it would mean a
lot for me if you guys can make some
time to come down to the show I don't
have the lineup in front of me maybe
I'll read that next week but it's just
basically a who's who and really just
let you know how well Greg was loved and
respected by all other comics so please
come down to the Wiltern theater in Los
Angeles on June 29th that's it that's
the podcast for this week I hope you
guys all have a great week and I hope
next week when I this is what I'm hoping
the Dallas Mavericks win the NBA
championship and the Bruins are the
Bruins are [ __ ] I actually have won
the Cup that would be amazing and I
still think that they could do it all
right that's it that's the podcast go
[ __ ] yourselves we'll talk to you next
week
another homie got smoked but it's no
surprise
everybody's trippin cuz the boy was too
young to die a sad sight to see my homie
take his last breath everybody's trippin
cuz they can't except my own instead
another killing was reported on the
evening news somebody's brother got just
behind a pair of shoes in the midst of
all this [ __ ] I think about myself
wondered when somebody's gonna try to
take me off the shelf but I refuse to be
another violent casualty so when I'm
reeling I pack my pistol grip beside my
knee cuts on the city streets today your
brother just can't win when the Pope do
you think are your friends really ain't
your friends and which we can't sleep
when everybody around me keeps falling
six feet the pain is deep inside of
everybody grows as they approach to see
the body before the chapter closed
the person standing next to me you
snapped the flip once I seen the captain
close I knew that that was it the whole
entire family spoke on his defense the
quiet son yourselves and make us
reminisce myself when I look at my
partner like why you broke into its
final song thinking to myself the worst
is yet to come
everyone was heading for the final
flight as we creep along the gravel on
the building site my little toast inside
the ground
everybody drop the flowers on the coffin
top and then the work below what the
concrete block immensity
a lot of homies died a lot of mothers
cry
i watch tears fall down from everybody
wants to go to heaven but nobody wants
to take the chance
they chose the music so they had that
they couldn't tell them nothing was a
player as they ever got caught up in the
game now my boys in the casket and
everybody's looking for somebody else to
blame a shame to let his mother know
that he was in the gang
we used to kick it out in the air that
night coming up trying to have the finer
things in life but not my boys count I
wish she was at home I wish she wouldn't
have never fell victim to the club so
when I drank a fool for you I put some
on the block son you might be dumb but
you damn showing for body so on remember
whenever on whatever did our live real
partners come together
you